So I just got back from a girls trip to Charleston,
South Carolina and while I had a really great time,
I was astounded by the amount of non masculine men
that I was surrounded by the whole time that I was there.
I'm not saying there weren't any masculine men,
but there were so many and I'm not used to that.
I'm from a farm community where men are very masculine and capable
and you know I felt so unsafe.
And I don't mean because I hate them,
that's not what I mean.
But if something catastrophic were to happen I just felt like who.
Who's gonna step up to the plate and like um, be responsible?
Who's going to be brave and like
stand up if something bad were to happen?
And I just felt like it just felt scary in a way to me. And
I was just thinking about it like
I am not gonna go to another female
when something bad or scary happens in my life.
I'm not gonna want them helping me.
I want a strong,
capable,
brave masculine man that I know can get the job done there to help me.
And it was so relieving to come home to my own wonderful husband
and just be here in this farm community again
where I know that's the way of life.